bonjour à tous et bonjour à nos
collègues de la commission des affaires
européennes et à son Président Madame
l'ambassadrice chère Président chers
collègues nous sommes donc
particulièrement heureux de vous
recevoir Madame pour un large tour
d'horizon de notre relation bilatérale
avec le Royaume-Uni puisque vous
représentez donc la France dans ce pays
depuis un peu plus de six mois
cette audition va être l'occasion de
rappeler l'importance déterminante du
dialogue franco-britannique dans notre
politique extérieure important souligné
par le fait que le roi Charles III
auquel vous avez récemment remis vos
lettres de créance aurait dû être
accueilli dans cette maison le mois
dernier à l'occasion de sa visite qui a
été à journée et qui semble être portée
me dit-on vers le mois de septembre plus
ça c'est les informations que m'a donné
la ministre à faire étrangère mais enfin
c'est certainement à confirmer
alors que l'année prochaine marquera le
120e anniversaire de l'entente cordiale
et sans revenir sur la riche histoire de
la coopération bilatérale entre nos deux
pays le partenariat entre la France et
le Royaume-Uni est un pivot structurant
aussi bien de notre politique étrangère
que de notre politique de défense en
dépit de divergence récente apparue en
2021 à l'occasion de la mise en œuvre du
brexit et de l'Alliance
ocus entre les Britanniques les
Australiens et les Américains dans
l'Indo Pacifique les politiques
extérieures de la France et du
Royaume-Uni demeurent étroitement lié et
c'est une bonne chose
les spécificités que la France partage
avec le Royaume-Uni en sa qualité de
puissance dotée de l'arme nucléaire et
membre permanents du Conseil de sécurité
constitue un facteur de rapprochement
qui transcende les désaccords ponctuels
qui peuvent survenir entre nos deux pays
l'échange de ce matin nous permettra
donc d'aborder l'ensemble des grands
enjeux de notre politique étrangère et
de défense à ce titre le bouleversement
géostratégique déclenché par l'agression
de l'armée russe en Ukraine le 24
février 22 est un témoignage de la
convergence structurelle qui existe
entre nos deux pays les autorités
britanniques ont fait partie de celles
qui ont réagi le plus vite et avec le
plus de détermination en soutien à
l'effort de guerre de l'Ukraine alors
que l'aide militaire du Royaume-Uni à
l'Ukraine est estimée à plus de 6
milliards et demi d'euros depuis le
début du conflit vous nous direz madame
quelle est la position actuelle du
gouvernement britannique sur le conflit
et dans quelle mesure son aide fait
l'objet d'une coordination efficace avec
celle apportée par l'Union européenne
c'est de dans ce contexte de convergence
géostratégique que le Président de la
République a accueilli le 10 mars
dernier le Premier ministre richissounac
à l'occasion d'un sommet
franco-britannique qui a permis
d'aborder de nombreux domaines de
coopération entre nous avant de revenir
sur les composants diplomatiques et
militaires de notre coopération je
souhaiterais profiter ici de l'après de
votre présence pour souligner
l'appartenance commune de la France et
du Royaume-Uni à l'Alliance atlantique
qui constitue un cadre déterminant pour
notre coopération bilatérale la semaine
dernière conformément à la volonté
commune de la France et du Royaume-Uni
la Finlande a pu rejoindre formellement
le temps après ratification de son
instrument d'adhésion par l'ensemble des
alliés pour autant le processus
d'adhésion reste en suspent pour la
Suède dont l'instrument d'adhésion doit
encore être ratifié par la Hongrie la
Turquie alors que la vision rapide de la
suédérien Atlantique est un objectif
partagé par la France et le Royaume-Uni
vous nous j'ai commencé deux pays qu'on
coordonne leur effort pour accélérer ce
processus sur le volet diplomatique de
notre relation bilatérale vous pourrez
également évoquer l'accueil fait au
Royaume-Uni au format de la communauté
politique européenne la CPE qui a été
proposée par le Président de la
République il y a un peu moins d'un an
après une première réunion à Prague en
octobre dernier qui a permis d'aborder
la question des infrastructures
critiques ainsi que le soutien à
l'Ukraine vous nous direz quelle est la
perception de ce nouveau format
diplomatique qui réunit 44 pays et
dépasse le périmètre de l'Union
européenne
en particulier quelques mois avant un
nouveau sommet en Moldavie premier juin
et un an avant la quatrième édition de
la CPE avant que celle-ci ne soit
organisée au Royaume-Uni vous ne direz
quel est le rôle que les britanniques
entendent jouer dans ce nouvel
instrument de politique extérieure qui
excède les limites de l'Union européenne
sur le volet militaire de notre relation
bilatérale nous serons heureux de vous
entendre nous préciser l'état
d'avancement de plusieurs projets de
coopération que nous avons sur ce plan
le cadre fixé par les accords de
Lancaster House du 2 novembre 2010
demeure bien sûr une référence
incontournable même si on n'a pas pu
célébrer cet anniversaire à l'époque
par suite alors que la longue mise en
œuvre du brexit a parfois donné le
sentiment de ralentir cette coopération
bilatérale on sera bien évidemment
attentif à votre analyse sur les
perspectives de coopération militaire
bilatérale en matière opérationnelle
vous pourrez nous rappeler le rôle des
10000 militaires de la force
expéditionnaire conjointe
franco-britannique et nous indiquer
quelle direction sont envisagées pour
renforcer son potentiel à moyen terme
enfin en matière capacitaire et alors
que le gouvernement a présenté la
semaine dernière le projet de loi de
programmation militaire nous serons
heureux de vous entendre sur les grands
projets industriels menés en commun et
en particulier sur l'état d'avancement
du futur missile anti navire et du futur
missile de croisière ainsi que du projet
one MBDA de création de centre
d'excellence partagée entre les filières
françaises et britanniques du groupe
vous voyez à l'évocation de tous ces
sujets combien votre audition est
importante pour la Commission des super
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées mais certainement mon collègue le
président rappin va aussi de la
commission d'affaires européennes
compléter mon propos
merci cher Christian madame
l'ambassadrice monsieur le Président
cher Christian mais mes chers collègues
nous sommes ravis de vous recevoir ce
matin madame l'ambassadrice c'est la
première fois qu'ensemble nos deux
commissions à faire étrangères défenses
et forces armées d'une part et à faire
européenne d'autre par vous entendre en
votre qualité de nouvelles ambassadrice
de France au Royaume-Uni je rappelle que
dès le brexit engagé nos commissions
mises en place un groupe commun sur le
sujet il s'attache à présent à suivre
l'évolution de la nouvelle relation
rubrique une délégation de ce groupe
c'est d'ailleurs rendue à Dublin et
Londres en octobre dernier juste avant
votre prise de fonction nous avions reçu
à plusieurs reprises votre prédécesseur
Madame Catherine Colonna dans le cadre
de notre groupe de suivi il faut dire
que la mise en œuvre des accords de
retrait et de commerce n'a pas été un
long fleuve tranquille c'est le moins
que l'on puisse dire
le protocole sur l'Irlande et l'Irlande
du Nord un excès à l'accord de retrait
en est l'illustration il fut sur ce de
vivre tension entre Londres et Bruxelles
pendant de nombreux mois face aux
difficultés constatées sur le terrain la
Commission européenne avait proposé en
octobre 2021 d'assouplir les conditions
de mise en œuvre du protocole malgré ses
propositions le climat de confiance dans
les négociations avait été altéré par la
décision de Boris Johnson prise en juin
2022 de déposer un projet de loi
prévoyant la désactivation unilatérale
de certaines stipulations du protocole
la relation britannique semblait avoir
semblait alors dans l'impasse il a fallu
attendre l'arrivée au pouvoir du nouveau
Premier ministre monsieur richissounac
pour entrevoir la possibilité d'une
issue
après des mois de négociation le Premier
ministre britannique et la présidente de
la Commission européenne ont finalement
annoncé le 27 février dernier la
conclusion d'un accord sur les
dispositions du protocole Nord irlandais
dit cadres de Windsor cet accord visal
léger les contrôles douaniers sanitaires
et phytosanitaires imposé au
marchandises provenant de grandes
Bretagne et entrant en Irlande du Nord
mais non destiné à être exporté en
Irlande c'est-à-dire dans l'Union
européenne cet accord largement salué
marque-t-il selon vous madame
l'ambassadrice l'ouverture d'un nouveau
chapitre dans la relation entre le
Royaume-Uni et l'Union européenne comme
a pu l'exprimer ma rose self-covic
vice-président de la Commission
européenne pourriez-vous nous indiquer
comment cet accord a été accueilli
outre-Manche
peut-on d'ailleurs vraiment espérer
qu'ils mettent fin au blocage politique
persistant en Irlande du Nord
outre la mise en oeuvre du protocole
d'autres points de crispation en venime
la relation euro-britannique depuis le
brexit a commencé par la pêche notre
commission s'est penché à plusieurs
reprises sur le sujet je me suis
également deux je suis également de très
près ce sujet en ma qualité d'élus du
Pas-de-Calais l'obtention de licence de
pêche pour accéder aux eaux britanniques
a été un combat long et difficile pour
nos pécheurs français il semblerait que
des tensions aient refait surface au
sujet des îles anglo-normandes de Jersey
et de Guernesey qui aurait durci les
modalités de permis de pêche pour
accéder à leurs eaux pourriez-vous nous
apporter des informations à ce sujet
par ailleurs la corde de commerce est de
coopération conclut entre l'Union
européenne et le Royaume-Uni réduit
progressivement de 25%, la part des
droits de pêche de l'Union européenne
dans les eaux britannique sur une
période de 5 ans et demi eu égard aux
tensions notamment s'agissant des
licences comment voyez-vous les
perspectives pour l'après 2026 où
l'accès aux eaux britanniques devra
faire l'objet d'une négociation annuelle
par ailleurs sur le même sujet alors que
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
a décidé d'examiner en début de semaine
la requête d'un demandeur d'Asie luxe
irakien menacé d'expulsion du
Royaume-Uni vers le Rwanda dans le cadre
d'un accord controversé entre Londres et
Kigali pourriez-vous nous indiquer
quelles sont les principales
dispositions du projet de loi
britannique contre l'immigration
illégale et où en est sa discussion sans
plus attendre madame l'ambassadrice je
vous cède la parole
Messieurs les Présidents madame les
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs je
vous remercie de m'accueillir et c'est
avec plaisir que je reconnais quelques
visages que j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer dans ma carrière et même
d'accueillir notamment lorsque j'étais
ambassadrice à l'OTAN j'ai auprès du
Conseil d'Atlantique Nord j'ai aussi et
j'aurai l'occasion d'accueillir un
certain nombre d'entre vous car je vois
que depuis quelques mois effectivement
j'ai pris mes fonctions il y a 5 mois je
sais que vous étiez venu un peu avant
mon arrivée mais je vois que les
contacts reprennent et que les missions
parlementaires comme d'ailleurs les
déplacements de ministres se multiplient
et c'est une c'est une bonne chose nous
accueillons d'ailleurs aujourd'hui même
des parlementaires sur les questions de
la diplomatie sportive alors je suis
heureuse évidemment d'avoir l'occasion
d'échanger avec nous avec vous sur la
relation franco-britannique après ce
sommet ce sommet qui est le 36e entre
nos deux pays et d'évoquer aussi le
cadre de Windsor et d'autres questions
que vous m'avez posées alors vous savez
le sommet de 10 mars c'était un moment
qui était attendu
attendu parce que cinq années c'était
écoulé entre le sommet de Sanders donc
2018 et celui de Paris qui a eu lieu le
mois dernier 5 années qui ont été
marqués comme vous l'avez dit par la
pandémie de covid qui a suspendu les
mouvements pour pour tout le monde le
retour de la guerre sur notre continent
la crise énergétique le retour de
l'inflation et puis aussi les tensions
liées à l'annonce du partenariat hocus
et puis évidemment pendant ces années le
Royaume-Uni a quitté a quitté l'Union
européenne cinq années c'est beaucoup il
faut garder à l'esprit que la plupart le
rythme du sommet britannique du
franco-britannique était depuis sa
création annuelle ou bise annuelle donc
cela donne aussi un sens à l'ampleur des
retrouvailles et le sens de cette de
cette rencontre
après le président de la République l'a
rappelé depuis lors de la conférence de
presse et il l'avait également dit lors
du sommet de Sanders il y a deux choses
que rien que rien ne peut changer dans
notre relation aucun vote aucune
décision politique aucune pandémie et
c'est la géographie et c'est notre
histoire nous avons une histoire
millénaire qui qui nous lie qui nous
oppose parfois et nous avons un passé
commun et puis nous avons aussi des
valeurs qui soudent notre solidarité et
nous avons eu une amitié des liens très
solides entre nous peuples il était
important de relancer des relations avec
un pays qui n'est plus membre de l'Union
européenne mais qui demeure un très
grand voisin et un très grand partenaire
alors je vais peut-être vous rappeler au
fond l'équilibre de ce partenariat
quelles sont les éléments d'abord dans
le champ économique la France est le
huitième client du Royaume-Uni et c'est
son sixième fournisseur c'est notre un
deuxième excédent commercial nous avions
5 milliards en 2022 et c'est le
troisième investisseur dans notre notre
pays et le 2 en termes d'emploi et aussi
c'est le troisième pays qui compte le
plus grand nombre de filiales françaises
et c'est quelque chose évidemment
d'essentiel en matière de défense vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président
le Royaume-Uni est notre premier
partenaire en termes d'interaction
opérationnelle entraînement mission
escale sur vol c'est peu connu mais
j'étais un major britannique et français
échangent en permanence à tous les
niveaux il y a de très nombreuses
officiels liaisons je suis à la nortweet
qui sont dans les différents états
majors c'est le premier partenaire et
réseau d'échanges en matière d'officier
de liaison et symétriquement la France
et le deuxième partenaire du Royaume-Uni
nous avons des domaines de coopération
multiple et même pendant les périodes
finalement les plus difficiles de notre
relation il y a une nombreuses qui ne se
sont pas arrêtées que ce soit sur la
coopération nucléaire dans d'autres
domaines
la présence avancée renforcée qui s'est
installé en Estonie et où nous faisons
groupe avec les Britanniques dans le
cadre d'une présence dissuasive et nous
sommes depuis 2017 et toujours donc
voilà il y a dans le domaine de la
défense une coopération étroite
historique et constante au niveau des
échanges humains certains on peut dire
que Londres était la troisième ville de
France je ne sais pas si c'est vrai mais
ce que nous savons en revanche c'est que
nous avons environ 250 000 compatriotes
qui résident au Royaume-Uni et que
parallèlement il y a 150 000
britanniques qui résident de façon
permanente dans notre pays et ça
évidemment c'est une richesse une
potentialité énorme mais aussi une
responsabilité vis-à-vis de ces
communautés il est important aussi que
la relation soit soit bonne pour pour
sur le plan de la coopération culturelle
on peut comme vous le savez compter sur
le dynamisme et du British consil et de
l'Institut français nous avons
le réseau les plus anciens nous avons
une antenne Édimbourg pour l'Institut
français nous avons 11 Alliances
françaises le français et la langue
étrangère la plus enseignée dans le
système éducatif britannique et nombre
de nos nombres de Britanniques par notre
langue même si aujourd'hui la
concurrence de l'Espagnol se fait de
plus en plus rude et je pense que nous
devons et nous y attachons entretenir
cette cette formation aux Français sur
le plan universitaire nous avons 92
diplômes entre nos pays et sur le plan
de la recherche le Royaume-Uni notre
premier partenaire scientifique en
termes de co-publication enfin et vous
l'avez dit en termes diplomatique comme
en deux États européens membres perdants
du Conseil de sécurité membre de l'Union
de l'Alliance atlantique et qui ont des
intérêts communs et des convergences
nombreuses de ce coordonnerait-il pas
c'est essentiel j'ai vu dans mes
anciennes fonctions que nous avons avec
les Britanniques très souvent une
approche très très similaire sur les
grands dossiers de ce monde que diront
l'Ukraine voilà donc honnêtement on a et
on partage l'engagement dans le
multilatéralisme et au fond il y a dans
les circonstances actuelles des éléments
qui nous invitent à nous rapprocher
davantage et c'était tout l'enjeu de ce
de ce sommet du 10 mars qui a marqué la
volonté de nos deux pays d'acroître leur
coopération à la hauteur de leur
responsabilité des enjeux en particulier
sur les sujets de sécurité de défense de
politique étrangères et aussi les
affaires globales de façon à répondre
aux attentes de nos concitoyens d'abord
et vous le savez nos deux pays font face
à un nouveau contexte international qui
place l'Europe au sens géographique du
terme face à des responsabilités
nouvelles la France et le Royaume-Uni
ont incontestablement un rôle majeur à
jouer pour faire prévaloir les principes
universitalistes et humanistes auxquels
ils sont fondamentalement attachés et
pour faire en sorte que l'Union
européenne et l'OTAN
coopèrent ensemble dans ce contexte moi
je veux saluer et c'est très vraiment
très important le virage qui a été pris
par le gouverneur britannique avec le
cadre Windsor qui marque et je le pense
sincèrement une volonté de réengagement
avec l'Union européenne et la
reconnaissance du besoin d'avoir avec
les Européens une relation stabilisée et
tournée vers la corde cet accord il est
important il ménage ce qui compte pour
nous c'est à dire
l'intégrité de notre marché intérieur
et
il maintient des contrôles nécessaires
pour les marchandises qui transit entre
l'Irlande du Nord vers lieu mais il
simplifie les procédures et c'est un
signal aussi politique positif pour la
préservation de la qui des accords du
vendredi saint qui dont nous avons fêté
vous le savez l'anniversaire en début de
semaine avec la présence du président
Joe Biden
[Musique]
qui s'est rendu à la fois en Irlande du
Nord et en plus de l'Irlande le cadre de
Windsor il permet aussi d'envisager la
poursuite de relations constructive
entre l'Union européenne et le
Royaume-Uni dans plusieurs domaines
s'agissant notamment les relations
économiques et financières de la
sécurité et de la politique étrangère
rétablir la confiance avec l'Union
européenne c'est essentielle dans ce
cadre que s'établisse notre relation et
vous m'avez posé me demander le Premier
ministre britannique a obtenu le soutien
d'une large majorité à la Chambre pour
pour valider cet accord et c'est un
travail qui a été préparé très très
étroitement une négociation qui a été
très très longue mais mais très bien
conduite et à mon avis des deux côtés
avec le souci de parvenir
il est clair que lors de la chambre à la
Chambre les Unionistes Nord irlandais et
plusieurs députés conservateurs ont fait
entendre leurs différences néanmoins cet
accord a été très très largement soutenu
évidemment il faudra être vigilant par
principe dans la mise en oeuvre de
l'accord mais le cadre de Windsor marque
un nouveau départ nous nous en
réjouissons et surtout c'était l'étape à
franchir pour recréer un lien avec avec
l'Union européenne
ce nouveau départ nous voulons le mettre
aussi à profit pour nous coordonner
davantage dans le soutien à l'Ukraine
qui nous partageons la même la même
analyse et la même volonté
la Russie ne peut ni ne doit gagner
cette guerre et la France et le
Royaume-Uni apporte un soutien l'Ukraine
depuis le 1er jour que ce soit sur le
plan humanitaire militaire et économique
et nous étroitement sur les sanctions
contre la Russie vous m'avez posé des
questions sur la coopération étroite il
y a même si les sanctions sont d'une
part européenne et de l'autre national
une radiation très étroite sur ce qui se
fait et vous verrez que vous constaterez
qu'il y a une bonne une bonne
synchronisation
et nos pays ont choisi aussi de mener
des actions concrètes notamment sur la
formation des militaires Ukrainiens sur
des segments opérationnels à haute
valeur vous avez vu par exemple les
marines et il y a pour faciliter la
coordination des officiers de liaison
dans la mission européenne et dans
britannique de façon à ce que
effectivement il n'y ait pas il n'y a
pas de doublon et puis nous travaillons
ensemble pour préparer les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois avec une
conviction commune il faudra trouver une
issue à ce conflit
c'est à dire une paix durable qui
respecte le droit international les
intérêts du peuple craignant nous allons
accroître aussi notre coopération pour
la reconstruction du crâne dans la
perspective que la conférence que
Londres organise en juin prochain donc
voilà donc pour proximité vraiment
proximité sur sur l'Ukraine coopération
et coordination évidemment nous nous
coordonnons aussi dans la perspective du
sommet de l'OTAN qui aura lieu en
juillet en juillet prochain et la
coopération a l'OTAN que j'ai que j'ai
pratiqué elle est évidemment étroite
nous avons nous avons des convergences
nous avons des convergences sur des
sujets qui sont des sujets des fois des
d'abord sur le la nécessité d'investir
dans la défense nous soutenons le
Royaume-Uni et la France soutiennent le
DIP le defense avec parfois des nuances
mais en tout cas nous souhaitons et nous
avons l'ambition d'avoir des budgets à
2% et même et même au-delà pour les
Britanniques et puis par ailleurs nous
avons aussi des discussions sur des
proximité sur des sujets tels que le
financement commun le fonctionnement le
fonctionnement de l'Alliance et puis
convergence aussi évidemment sur la
nécessité de soutenir l'Ukraine et aussi
au fond sur la question de la présence
avancée cette présence que nous avons
que nous avons ensemble que nous avons
ensemble en Estonie et que nous
maintenons après vous avez évoqué la
communauté politique européenne
à laquelle le Royaume-Uni a décidé de
participer c'est une décision qui avait
été annoncée comme vous le savez avant
le premier sommet de la CPE à Prague
donc début octobre et c'est d'ailleurs
stress à l'époque qui s'était rendu au
sommet de la CPE il y aura vous le savez
un sommet en Moldavie en juin prochain
puis ensuite ce sera l'Espagne et puis
le Royaume-Uni
[Musique]
qui nous concerne à lieu pour renforcer
notre résilience collective face à
menace russe et aussi à d'autres menaces
ensuite comme vous le savez cette ce
sommet de Paris c'est également
l'occasion de renforcer notre
coopération en matière de sécurité de
défense et les très lances des accords
de Lancaster House elle est très forte
et les accords de Lancaster House c'est
quelque chose d'assez unique il s'agit
de renforcer aussi l'interopérabilité
opérationnelle tant sur le plan
technique etc
le thé opérabilité c'est parfois peu
visible mais c'est en fait essentiel
quand des armées veulent travailler
ensemble ce sont des questions simples
de convergence des radios de capacité de
100 ans et de se comprendre mais c'est
très important vous avez évoqué le
projet de missile effectivement nous
voulons avancer avec un calendrier
ambitieux c'est 2030 c'est marqué dans
la dans la déclaration pour le futur
missile anti navire et le futur missile
de croisière et nous voulons avancer
aussi sur l'interopérabilité de nos
systèmes aériens futurs respectifs et
puis nous avons des projets des projets
nouveaux en tout cas des domaines que
nous voulons explorer ensemble qui sont
c'est lui des armes à énergie dirigées
ou de la maîtrise des fonds marins donc
beaucoup beaucoup de sujets ont continué
évidemment sur la plupart des des sur
les sujets qui ont été lancés dans
Lancaster House sur les coopérations
aussi de coopérations nucléaires mais il
y a d'autres domaines que nous
souhaitons que nous souhaitons explorer
ensemble
ce renforcement de capacité il est
évidemment indispensable pour penser les
termes de la sécurité européenne de
demain nous pensons aussi et vous en
avez parlé
adapter le potentiel de Sitges donc
cette force expéditionnelle conjoint
expérimenter conjointe dont nous avons
déclaré il y a peu de temps
l'opérationnelle
nous voulons l'adapter aux nouvelles
environnement de sécurité et aux
nouvelles régions contestées telles que
par exemple Grand Nord nous voulons
aussi améliorer la coopération en
matière de logistique et accroître les
échanges du renseignement en soutien aux
opérations et d'une manière très
concrète faciliter l'accès des de chacun
au base militaire de l'autre par
ailleurs le sommet de Paris et vous
l'avez peut-être vu dans la déclaration
a marqué la volonté de nos deux pays de
renforcer la coordination de leur
déploiement militaire maritime dans la
région adopacifique en vue d'assurer une
présence européenne pérenne dans la
région
dans le domaine du nucléaire militaire
qui est un domaine de coopération très
très important et très structuré les
travaux se poursuivent dans le cadre de
ce qu'on appelle la JNC c'est-à-dire la
commission nucléaire conjointe et dans
le domaine du nucléaire civile il y a
tout un volet il y a eu pendant ce
sommet tout un volet industriel
économique qu'il ne faut pas perdre de
suite de vue dans le domaine du
nucléaire civil le chantier de
inclipoint c'est c'est la concrétisation
la plus visite de la coopération
franco-britannique puisque EDF construit
deux EPR et il y a le projet de size
Buell c que nous souhaitons pleinement
et qui devrait être aussi l'occasion
d'un nouveau dynamisme économique et
avec l'hypothèse de conduit de deux
opère supplémentaires
alors le sommet de Paris il a également
marqué notre volonté de renforcer la
coordination en matière de décoration et
d'énergie renouvelable et aussi nous
voulons travailler ensemble à la réforme
de l'architecture financière
international en préparant le sommet de
Paris du 23 juin sur le nouveau pacte
financier alors vous avez évoqué la
question de l'immigration irrégulière et
vous savez que c'est un sujet sur lequel
la coopération franco-britannique est
essentielle je tiens à dire que d'abord
les pays travaillent ensemble depuis
longtemps
je voulais vous donner quelques chiffres
sur ce qui se fait enfin en tout cas
ceux qui apparaît
à titre d'exemple en 2022 la France et
le Royaume-Uni ont empêché plus de 1300
traversées d'embarcation de fortune nous
avons des mots clés 55 filières de
criminalité organisées et nous avons
procédé à plus de 500 arrestations grâce
au travail de la cellule de
renseignements conjointe
franco-britannique alors vous le il y a
eu plusieurs étapes et notamment le 14
novembre dernier la France et le
Royaume-Uni ont conclu un cadre bilarité
pour la lutte contre l'immigration
régulière et lors du sommet de Paris il
y a aussi une étape supplémentaire
puisque nous avons décidé au delà de
l'importance contribution régulière
française car la France investit
beaucoup de moyens dans cette dans cette
lutte le britanniques se sont engagés
sur une contribution pluriannuelle
durant les trois années à venir qui
s'élèvera à 141 millions d'euros pour
20223 23 24 1811 pour l'année suivante
et 209 pour 25 26 concrètement pourquoi
cette contribution le Royaume-Uni a
accepté de financer le format de 500
nouveaux membres de services
opérationnels et d'autres ressources
humaines en france pour faire des
patrouilles et investir dans de
nouvelles infrastructures et de nouveaux
équipements de surveillance parce que
les patrouilles sont d'autant plus
efficaces qu'il y a de surveillance
électronique qui permettent au fond
d'avoir des patrouilles dans des
endroits plus circonscrits et de façon à
avoir des des détections rapides des
tentatives de traverser et ces
investissements ce sera davantage de
drones d'hélicoptère d'aéronef cela
aussi permettra d'accroître on permet et
à l'intention d'être les capacités de
gestion des migrants irréguliers
notamment par la création d'un centre de
rétention qui permettra d'améliorer
d'accroître le nombre des retours et de
prévenir de nouvelles tentatives de
traverser
vous avez évoqué les questions de les
questions de pêche alors ça n'était pas
au centre des discussions du sommet tout
simplement parce que il n'y a pas les
échéances sur la pêche sont de 2026
après vous comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président les discussions
sur la pêche ont été difficiles et vous
savez l'accord de commerce cette
coopération prévoit un accès aux eaux
britanniques pour les batteurs européens
qui pêchaient précédemment mais que la
mise en œuvre a été serait difficile
notamment pour la zone des 6-12
et pour les à la fois pour la zone
et notamment président anglo nord-vente
et notamment pour les bateaux de moins
de 12 mètres et on a eu à l'époque enfin
à l'époque des tensions diplomatiques ce
qui avait valu d'ailleurs à ma
prédécesseur d'être convoqué au
ministère des Affaires étrangères ce qui
est quand même pas ce qui n'est pas
fréquent
après à la suite de tout cela il y a eu
des travaux approfondis qui ont été
conduits par la Commission et aussi par
les autorités qui sait pas car comme
vous savez c'est la Commission qui
négocie et aussi par les autorités
françaises auprès de
britannique et la situation ses apaisée
après comme vous l'avez dit il y a des
sujets qui restent parfois compliqué
au-delà des octroissances et en
particulier sur l'ampleur de l'activité
des navires de lieu dans les autres
Jersey et Guernesey ou encore la notion
de
bateau remplaçante nous sommes très
vigilants et attent et la poursuite la
poursuite de ces échanges est importante
de façon à ce qu'il puisse continuer
leur activité dans les eaux donc voilà
il a mis en place d'une concert
d'instance de concertation locale est
importante alors vous avez parlé de
l'échéance de 2026 et évidemment c'est
une échange très importante et nous
l'avons nous l'avons bien en tête ici
mais nos représentants à Bruxelles l'ont
aussi évidemment nous attacherons à des
plans à déployer au mieux au niveau
européen à défendre nos fins des
intérêts de nos pêcheurs comme cela a
été fait tout au long la négociation de
l'accord de commerce et de coopération
alors les ascension britannique à ce
stade sont peu précises
et la position britannique devra de
toute façon intégrer les positions des
nations parce que comme vous le savez
peut-être c'est une matière d'évolue la
pêche après il y aura des élections
générales l'an prochain donc il est
assez normal que les orientations soient
plus tard néanmoins il est clair que on
sera très très mobilisé et qu'on a cet
échange bien en tête après comme vous le
savez avant même 2026 il y a un certain
nombre de sujets que nous regardons déjà
notamment le déploiement de nouvelles
politiques de pêche en remplacement de
la politique commune européenne et
notamment la question des zones
protégées des règles de façon à
évidemment et la Commission est très
vigilante de façon à voir que ça ne ça
ne laisse pas ça ne laisse pas nos
péchés enfin en tout cas sur la question
la question de la pêche je suis bien je
suis bien au courant j'ai travaillé sous
l'autorité de Jean-Yves Le Drian qui
était fort attentif donc rassurez-vous
et nos autorités et nos représentants à
Bruxelles le son aussi alors je voulais
aussi vous parler d'un sujet qui est
important c'est ce que l'on appelle
enfin le lien entre les sociétés et les
liens les liens humains comme je vous
l'ai dit nous avons
300 12 français Royaume-Uni 150 000
britanniques en France et je pense que
ce sommeil était important pour renouer
le lien entre les sociétés
parce qu'il ne faudrait pas qu'avec le
temps et avec au fond la limitation des
échanges humains nos deux sociétés se
perdent se perdent de vue et donc nos
pays se sont engagés lors du sommet de
Paris approfondir encore leur
coopération culturelle éducative et
scientifiques nous allons tracer et
travailler à faciliter la mobilité en
particulier de la jeunesse dans le
respect de nos engagements et du cadre
européen et c'est un point d'engagement
d'engagement pour majeur pour nous et
c'est pour la raison pour laquelle nous
avons souhaité qu'un dialogue sur la
mobilité puisse être engagé avec les
Britanniques parce que investir sur la
jeunesse et investir sur l'avenir et je
pense que c'est dans ce cadre que doit
se concevoir notre relation nous avons
maintenant nous regardons vers l'avenir
déjà 2024 la commémoration évidemment du
120e anniversaire de en tant que cordial
et leur présentation nationale nos
collectivités territoriales les dizaines
de jumelages qui vivent aux deux les
communes doivent vraiment participer
voilà alors j'ai été longue mais
finalement bref par rapport à ce qui
tout ce qu'il y a dans la déclaration
que je vous invite à lire parce qu'il y
a la relance d'un dialogue alors c'est
la relance d'un dialogue ça n'est pas
l'aboutissement dans de très nombreux
domaines que ce soit l'énergie le
domaine économique mais le souhait en
tout cas de reprendre et sans doute
aussi par ce dialogue de mieux se
comprendre et de mieux anticiper les
éventuels difficultés voilà je vous
remercie et je suis à votre disposition
pour répondre à vos questions et
n'hésitez pas si mes réponses ne vous
conviennent pas à les reposer merci
Madame
ambassadrice pour tous ces points comme
vous l'avez dit c'est la relance d'un
dialogue et encore effectivement sur
sur le
l'ouvrage sur le métier un ouvrage
sérieux à
consolider donc si vous le voulez bien
on va passer à la séquence de questions
de nos collègues
et donc on va commencer par Claude Kern
puis Didier Marie et Louis Jean de
Nicolay
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
l'ambassadrice pour votre présence ce
matin majorité un peu plus spécifique
qui porte sur une loi qui a été
promulgué le 23 mars dernier au
Royaume-Uni et qui concerne les salaires
des marins
cette loi permettra aux autorités
britanniques de sanctionner voire de
refuser l'accès au port du royaume au
navire ne rémunérant pas leur marin ou
sa leur minimum national
d'ailleurs une proposition de loi
similaire a été adoptée à l'Assemblée
nationale française le 28 mars dernier
et doit être examiné prochainement au
Sénat ces textes s'inscrivent dans la
continuité de l'affaire bientôt ferries
qui a licencié l'an dernier sans préavis
800 britanniques pour les remplacer par
une main d'oeuvre bon marché et créant
ainsi des conditions d'une concurrence
déloyale sur le transmanche tout le
monde s'accorde sur la nécessité de
protéger nos marins de cette concurrence
déloyale mais le salaire minimum
britannique et le salaire minimum
français divergent
alors dans l'hypothèse ou la proposition
de loi adoptée à l'Assemblée nationale
serait adoptée au Sénat quelle
coordination
pourrait s'opérer entre le Royaume-Uni
et la France afin de veiller à ce que le
régime social le plus protecteur pour
les Français a pour les marins pardon
s'applique aux liaison transmanche
merci président
merci Madame l'ambassadrice pour
l'ensemble de vos propos qui ont déjà
permis d'aborder un grand nombre de
sujets
moi je voudrais y revenir sur la
situation économique et sociale en
Grande-Bretagne
cela fait maintenant plusieurs mois que
des mouvements de grève importants ont
lieu
un mot d'ordre de débrayage total a été
lancé par les partenaires sociaux
et je voulais avoir votre analyse sur la
part des conséquences du brexit sur
cette situation économique et sociale au
regard de ce que nous connaissons des
conséquences à la fois de la crise
sanitaire et de la guerre en Ukraine et
des répercussions politiques que ça peut
avoir à court et moyen terme
en Grande-Bretagne
les sondages
en Grande-Bretagne à Tess que les
Britanniques ont un sentiment légère du
brexit qui a fortement évolué puisque
une majorité d'entre eux considère que
c'était une erreur et que d'autres parts
les gouvernements successifs n'ont pas
répondu comme il se devait à cette
situation
voilà ça dénote d'un contexte
particulier et donc ce serait
intéressant de d'avoir votre sentiment
sur cette situation et sur le climat
social qui en résulte merci
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
l'ambassadrice vous avez évoqué
l'ensemble des sujets moi j'aurais trois
sujets un peu plus précis le premier
vous avez parlé de la mobilité ce que
vous sentez que au sujet des races
muscles il y a une un sentiment
d'évolution vers quelque chose de plus
simple pour l'ensemble des des étudiants
européens ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est est-ce que la
coopération spatiale qui était qui est
une coopération européenne mais ce
qu'une coopération spatiale dont vous
avez un sentiment que le gouvernement
actuel là aussi souhaite se rapprocher
de l'Europe à nouveau pour qu'il y ait
une véritable coopération spatiale et
enfin le dernier point c'est sur la
cyber
criminalité ou la cyber-surveillance
avec le chasseur jptique les Italiens
notamment aussi sont en train de de
calmer sur leur territoire est-ce que là
aussi
ce côté là une nouvelle coopération une
coopération plus rapprochée avec avec
l'Europe pourrait avoir lieu et puis
enfin le dernier petit point c'est sur
il semblerait que il y a une ouverture
vers la coopération financière entre
l'Angleterre de nouveau et l'Europe et
notamment avec le change et puis
l'ensemble des Bourses européennes Paris
et Francfort est-ce que on a ce
sentiment que on va retrouver un avant
brexit à ce niveau là pour permettre des
flux plus plus facile entre entre le
Royaume-Uni et l'ensemble de l'Europe
merci beaucoup alors d'abord sur la
question du salaire du salaire des
marins donc du dumping social alors là
aussi je vous renvoie sur je vous
renvoie la déclaration conjointe qui a
évoqué cette question parce que c'est
effectivement une question importante
des deux côtés de la Manche et dans ce
le déclaration du sommet on a écrit la
France et le Royaume-Uni s'efforceront
d'améliorer les conditions sociales des
gens de maire en accordant la priorité à
leur santé alors sécurité et
présenteront ainsi tous les deux de
manière indépendante des projets de loi
alors Parlement respectifs protégeant
ces personnes contre l'exploitation et
vous savez que le gouvernement
britannique est effectivement très très
attentif à ses avancées qui font suite
comme vous l'avez dit au licenciement
brutal je des 800 marins de PO de
printemps dernier de notre côté la
France défend aussi depuis longtemps et
dans le cadre de l'Union européenne
l'établissement de standard minimum pour
les gens de mer et évidemment
souhaitable les entreprises qui
respectent les règles relatives au
salaire minimum national et je pense à
britanniférisme n'est pas à souffrir
d'une forme de dumping social de la part
de certaines compagnies étrangères alors
le Royaume-Uni a promué le 23 mars
dernier le cifer 2023 qui prévoit que
les personnels employés sur des navires
effectuant des liaisons régulières plus
de 120 par an à partir d'un port
britannique et une rémunération au moins
égale au salaire minimum national et
cela permet il prévoit aussi que les
autorités portuaires demandent aux
opérateurs d'attester du respect de
cette règle et leur impose le paiement
d'une pénalité en cas de défaut et des
contrôles surpies et sur place devraient
être effectuées sur les navires pour
s'assurer du respect de ses règles et
puis par ailleurs le gouvernement a pris
en janvier toujours pour faire suite au
cas piano disposition qui visitent à
limiter l'usage des pratiques dites fire
vous savez qui permettent aux
entreprises de licencier des personnes
et puis de les réembaucher immédiatement
après dans des conditions moins
favorables et donc les entreprises qui
l'usage de cette menace pour faire
accepter leurs employés des conditions
moins avantageuses pourront désormais
être condamnés par les tribunaux à leur
verser des compensations supplémentaires
vous avez évoqué un projet de texte en
France
dont je dois reconnaître que je ne
connais pas l'économie mais vous sans
doute et évidemment on sera attentif à
ce que il n'y a pas trop il n'y ait pas
de de divergence entre en tout cas de
Gap quand le texte quand le texte sera
voté et qui sera qui sera dans le
domaine public donc voilà en tout cas je
merci de
m'alerter sur ce sur ce sujet
ensuite j'ai eu des questions sur fond
les conséquences les conséquences du
brexit sur la situation sociale
économique je vous remercie c'est une
question à laquelle il est difficile de
répondre pour beaucoup de raisons et
aussi tout simplement parce que les
conséquences sont
difficile à anticiper parce que beaucoup
de choses beaucoup de choses se mêlent
d'abord parce qu'il y a eu des
phénomènes d'anticipation des acteurs
économiques des conséquences du brexit
avant même l'accord de retrait ou que
l'accord de commerce ou l'accord de
commerce de coopération était ratifiée
et on pense aussi que il y a eu un effet
coup près au 1er janvier mais aussi il y
a des facteurs il y a eu des facteurs
conjoncturels et évidemment la période
de covid qui fait que la plupart des
économies redémarrent redémarrent
doucement et puis aussi il y a eu des
facteurs plus structurels qui sont des
détournements de flux de commerce on
voit par exemple que par la République
d'Irlande il y a de plus en plus de flux
et donc je pense que c'est difficile de
répondre de façon exhaustive et
précise ce qui est ce qui éclaire c'est
que il y a eu et ça ces documenté par
l'office pour budget responsabilité
pense qu'il y a eu un impact sur la
productivité une perte de productivité
et aussi
un affaiblissement durable dans le pays
mais voilà c'est très au fond c'est
compliqué de répondre de façon de façon
unie unilatérale et de façon définitive
et je pense que je pense que c'est voilà
il faut il faut étudier étudier la chose
de façon plus approfondie après il y a
eu voilà je pense qu'il faut prendre la
part des choses et notamment le volet la
suite de la suite de la pandémie et les
impacts après il est clair que les
prévisions économiques du FNI ne sont
pas ne sont pas positives aujourd'hui
mais pour l'instant évidemment c'est une
prévision l'Orb pense que les prévisions
de croissance seront de moins 0,2 - 0,2%
voilà quant au débat au débat
britannique sur sur le brexit ça n'est
pas à moi de ça n'est pas moi d'en juger
il est clair que les positions sont en
train sont en train d'évoluer néanmoins
c'est un sujet qui est très qui est très
évolutif et qui on verra dans la dans la
durée
après vous m'avez interrogé aussi sur
Erasmus
pour l'instant on voit peu d'évolution
mais je pense que c'est un sujet
effectivement très important pour la
connaissance de nos sociétés qu'il
faudra si on peut si on veut
améliorer la améliorer les choses alors
le cadre de winstore il va permettre si
les Britanniques le souhaitent
la participation l'association de du
Royaume-Uni au programme Horizon 20 20
ce sera déjà une façon de relier et
d'avoir plus d'échanges entre entre les
chercheurs et peut-être que ça aidera
aussi à susciter les choses sur les
étudiants vous avez évoqué
aussi la question du cyber et il est
clair que sur ces questions nous avons
de très bonnes coopérations historiques
et aussi actuelle avec le Royaume-Uni et
nous avons décidé à l'occasion du sommet
de relancer le dialogue le dialogue sur
le cyber et donc voilà c'est un sujet
qui va aussi sur lequel on va on va
avancer voilà
je remercie
bien merci infiniment madame
l'ambassadrice pour cet échange qui est
très utile et qui
nous permet à la fois de bien situer la
portée des
de ce qui reste à faire pour relancer
cette coopération qui a subi
effectivement les suites du brexit mais
la page est tournée donc bien évidemment
nous vous remercions de tous les efforts
qui sont faits notamment des efforts que
nous ferons ensemble pour faire en sorte
que les échanges inter parlementaires
puissent être reprendre du reste le
rythme qui n'a jamais cessé au demeurant
puisque pendant le brexit on avait c'est
peut-être la période du reste on a eu le
plus souvent de contact avec des des
visites fréquentes de part et d'autre
mais nous attachons beaucoup
d'importance notamment pour le ma
commission à faire cet engère défense
bien évidemment à ce qui est sur ces
sujets
des échanges fréquents merci donc
infiniment pour pour cet échange